[Applaudissements]
plus petit chéri il rentre comme ça en
catimini et jingle deviendra jingle
libre et déguisements rien à lui rien si
le déguiser alors bonsoir merci d'être
là mais ça merci à vous alors même eric
6r cédric scan l'actus isère ce cas là
qu est ce qu on a une gueule un truc non
vous vous en foutez il ya des problèmes
techniques merce alors allez-y bah si tu
t'en sors écoute tu me tiens au courant
a ajouté je vais essayer alors cyril
vous savez je suis un spécialiste média
bien sûr constamment à maxime dénis là
ne manquez pas ça parce que vous allez
revenir ça vous allez revenir sur
ballons ce ton post dont un prime et sur
le prime des animaux était un des plus
beaux prime qu'on ait fait depuis
alors que j'étais en régie et dans ma
loge je me suis rien au dessus de ouf
justement elle pas similaire pourquoi
parce que la semaine dernière j'ai lancé
un sondage auprès des téléspectateurs et
je leur ai demandé quelle était la pire
émission de l'histoire des télévisions
et regarder 100% les téléspectateurs ont
répondu ou fin et matthieu delormeau
mais heureusement ce sondage été lancé
la semaine dernière parce qu'à mon avis
c'était pmp fait sans bêtise et spécial
animaux qui aurait gagné largement pas
c'était vendredi soir sur ses 8 alors
est présenté par quelle vidéo vedette tu
faisais que jamais alors bachand et
kelly ils s'en sont bien sortis très
bien sorti vous allez voir alors j'ai un
petit vries est ce que vous soulevez
ciric à l'école quand le prof arriver
avant qu'il arrive on se mettait tous à
sa place on va l'économie etc
et dès qu'ils arrivent et repartent à
nos places sans qu'ils disent rien du
tout mais j'ai remarqué c'est un petit
peu la même chose quoi le vendredi quand
vous arrivez en plateau regarder pour
balances ton post c'est exactement
pareil regardez-moi ça
alors c'est le patron arrive et là
regardez automatiquement les deux années
vont rejoindre directeur place de
chroniques et là on va découvrir que
vous allez kiffer le prime et que vous
savez remercier le travail de mon équipe
regardez vous avez passé une bonne
journée aller de tous ces gens là 2,9 à
ce prime
gilles verdez ça vous a plu
formidable à petit
alors on a pas du voir la même personne
[Applaudissements]
magali berda franchement joue du doc
vous des vues sur le quiz formidable il
faut dire merci à magali berlin pour son
dernier prime
[Applaudissements]
après il se dit déjà évoqué l atalante
la belle unanimité sans moi je me
souvenais pas de ça qu'on parlait mais
bon j'ai moi aussi qui assurait alors
qu'il avait mariama aussibal l'oms est
en niveau 1 et 2 les deux ensembles suis
pas sûr mais séparément des prix ce week
end en informera à regret prochainement
non j'ai dit un temps kelly montiel ça
serait bien justement
oh oui on y pense à aller on va faire
peut-être cailly montiel kenny castany
kanye quelqu'un qui aime vivre à l'écart
kenny chez elle ou non c'est pas vrai
est d'accord non non c'est bon alors
voilà mais c'est vrai ce serait bien non
on a on a envie de travailler aussi avec
bara mondiale et bien sûr sinon cela va
faire un prime aussi tout seul la fin
février
d'accord très bien m'a dit maman le
temps est chaud 32 février non non non
non je n'y reviens bientôt il reviendra
il est en train de s'occuper de sa jambe
et la save est en train de très bien se
passer pour le problème quand on fait
une spéciale animaux etc à isabelle
c'est qu'on sait qu'elle va parler sans
arrêt c'est comme si on faisait un prime
pour les moustaches valérie pas leurs
époux le temps chaud
c'est donc sur deux heures de prime on a
eu autant d'anecdotes d'isabelle qui
fait raconter une petite histoire daigle
au liban j'ai assisté à une opération
daigle savais que c'était brise une pâte
j'ai eu une chatte siamoise hockey après
en charge 1 petit oignon savait que
l'agneau sous la mer noire avait
condamné si un jour il ya là finalement
le seul animal qui survivraient c'est le
chat parce que j'adapte abla tout va
très bien et attention ça qu'il avait
bien du subprime sont là pour la brûler
on la brûle le bruit de la casse il n'y
a pas eu de monsieur dans cette émission
est aussi de très mauvaise chose
regardez bon heureusement jean michel
maire était en mode lourdeur olympique
un mur sien il ya des grands des petits
à poil sans poils mauget et si vous
étiez un animal vous ce serait quoi
anna combat tu m'étonnes alors vous
allez voir que niveau divertissement
n'est sur un énorme prime mais sur idf1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et gilles a même dansé sur le générique
de balancement pose alors pour les
textes de lancement ils sont pas emmerdé
genre prix les fiches de guy lux et
denise fabre qui date de 1963
vous aimez les choux j'adore les si vous
aimez les animaux
j'adore les uns vous aimez les animaux
qui chutent pourquoi pas chez vous des
meilleurs amis non mais c'est de la
merde oui on a fait preuve de beaucoup
de généraux et écoute et on aime tu
écoutais le public attend le public
thème le public torikka je vais pleurer
merci donc on en est donc un ballon ce
ton post qui avait lieu ce week-end oui
oui c'est tellement long que c'est la
seule émission qui est sur trois jours a
fini à deux ans et demi commence à
chaque fois un vrai film adam mais à ce
rythme là moi je finis les missions
juillet à regarder qu'à regarder nous
intéresser bon c'est clair moi j'ai
regardé jusqu'au bout et la cgc à vous
dire sur la séquence voyants sont au
vert de rivella d'après dire un truc de
fou vous prenez un truc qui est arrivé
aujourd'hui non jour ses amis ils font
flipper potable on veut savoir malik
sont confiés bekwai à la règle et rex
direction et l'autre qui rigolaient
quand elle a entendu érection c'est
comme en classe quant à l'entente un
gros mois et tout
allez vas-y la semaine dernière toute la
presse a salué le nouveau cyril hanouna
regardez cyril hanouna le le médiateur
cyril hanouna le relais entre le pouvoir
et le peuple
souvenez vous des questions abordées la
semaine dernière avec madame la ministre
des résultats sur cette suppression de
l' iss vous vouliez faire concrètement
augmenté aussi le smic
le crédit d'impôt pour la compétitivité
et l'emploi réservé aux tpe et pme
alors forcément vendredi soir cyril vous
êtes resté le cyril hanouna
éditorialistes ce que vous y travaillez
à cette histoire de lire dans les easy
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
lui vous avez recueilli la fée patron
incognito
on va voir que vous réussissez à être
sérieux pendant deux heures le troisième
thème vous allez replonger dans le monde
de la barca pourquoi cette loi
anticasseurs pour vous et la bonne
solution qu'on est il aujourd'hui de ces
diane east et là vous craquez voilà le
cyril hanouna de touche pas à mon poste
resurgit alors vous lisez l'avenir sur
le sexe des gens voyez les choses dans
les bouches
on vous avait à saint dizier un jour à
l'angle ayant vous appelle vous dit
attendre attendre minutes sans clientèle
et les russes vous allez enlever hot
lips et vous allez passer chiffres il
était deux heures du matin non pas des
gens du matin raconte béton la question
série c est ce qu ensuite elle a proposé
de devoir lire dans les baux louis alors
rename c'est ça votre problème mais
encore on est en droit de savoir parce
qu'elle a des halles est certainement eu
envie non non je vous dis non non non
non non alors à la personne a proposé de
venir dans les boules personne n'a vu
dans les boues chaulées personne ne lira
dans les bouges comme je vous le dis je
vais vous dire au risque pour risque pas
de voir l'avenir
vous risquez plutôt que par le passé
alors une femme exceptionnelle vendredi
soir way deborah on peut faire
connaissance avec mieux donc vous faites
par les personnes décédées à travers
vous et vous changer de voie en fait
quand vous en quelque sorte je sens
d'intonation elle devrait être aussi
changer son rire ses pattes
[Rires]
alors bien son ami alan et mystique vous
apprécié votre avenir serrer la main des
bons bien sûr que je suis est bien bien
funky town n'a alors lui j'ai dans le
collimateur parce que ces derniers temps
belle à ces chiffres certains moi je
peux te dire une chose c'est que il va
il va pas tarder à se prendre à une
petite prime par tête mais lieu c'est
déjà il devrait encore payer pour finir
j'ai que pendant la pub vendredi déborah
et roro ont tenu à donner l'avenir de
certains chroniqueurs alors on regarde
ça tout va le faire accepter de se
marier mais ça sera un déclic mais rodez
qui devaient y va tripler son nombre
d'interventions en touche pas à mon
poste clé madame des journées par les
trois fois par émission de 6 min fera
meilleure preuve que le bêtisier cet
hymne au vendredi en même temps c'est
pas difficile ainsi rien nous n'avons
augmenter tous les chroniqueurs qui
limite d'une personne
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
m